>>Right now we're in the
middle of our DNA unit.
We can get you caught
up but I need you
in class every single day,
no ifs, ands, or buts.
Actions speak louder words.
>>Sarah Revis is in trouble.
She's failing several classes because
she hasn't been to school in a month.
>>I do think that you're one
of the most capable students.
>>If she were part of
the general population
at Andrew Hill High School, her
teachers might simply write her off.
But she's a member of the school's
Biotech Academy, a close-knit family
of at-risk students
and dedicated teachers
for whom failure is not an option.
>>This has got to change.
Do I need to call mom?
Honestly, if you want me to call mom.
>>No.
>>Then I won't okay?
Is this going to change?
>>Yes.
>>Okay when?
>>Today.
>>And if not?
>>Then I'll be out of Biotech.
>>So?
>>I want to go to college and
I probably won't graduate.
>>So?
>>And that matters to me.
>>Narrator: Graduating from Biotech
has changed the lives of hundreds
of students since the
academy was founded
on Andrew Hill High School's
San Jose campus in 1999.
>>Okay remember how it works.
The [inaudible] if it's going left or
right is closed, up and down is open.
>>Biotech Academy is
sort of the cornerstone
of the school, our trademark.
>>Forty-five.
Forty-five minus.
>>We wanted to provide opportunities
for students who were, you know,
in that category of maybe marginal
or at-risk because our concept was
if you have a program that these
students can be connected to,
that's going to increase the
probability that they're going
to stay in school and
matriculate to either a two-year
or four-year college university.
>>Narrator: Each fall 50 sophomores
enter the three-year academy program
which features an interdisciplinary
curriculum focused on bioscience.
Juniors are hooked up with mentors
at local biotechnology companies
and as seniors they present the
results of self-designed experiments.
>>Our first lab was
actually getting the rats
and putting them in the tanks.
>>While only 30 percent of the
school's general population goes
on to college, the rate for Biotech
Academy students is 95 percent.
>>Can you see that?
>>No.
>>Can you see the paper
in front of you?
>>Yes.
>>Good.
>>Much of the credit for
the academy's success goes
to a unique team of teachers.
>>Imperialism in Africa.
>>The teachers in this
program were hand-picked.
Criteria was first that they
were high-energy communicators
that understood how to reach kids.
>>The English come down and
they're like "Move over"
to the Dutch, "move over, move over."
And the Dutch are like, go ahead,
the Dutch are like
"Move back, move back."
And so they're going
to end up doing what?
What are the English and
the Dutch going to be doing?
>>Student: Fighting.
>>Christine: Fighting.
>>The relationship that we have with
these kids is completely unique.
The way we speak, the
"What are you doing?
Where are you going?
Why aren't you supposed
to be in class?
Let me see your grades?
What- what are you doing?"
They respond; for some
reason it works for them.
>>Matt: Okay so this is
what we're going to do.
We have to figure out what is the
concentration of an unknown acid.
Okay?
>>It's kind of hard because basically
you have such a wide range from kid
that are extremely intelligent
but just aren't trying to kids
that need a lot of hand-holding.
>>The last class still was
confused so we'll try it again.
Unknown acid, okay.
>>Coming from the suburbs of Chicago
I did not grow up the same way
as these kids are growing
up so it's very difficult
for me to relate lots of times.
Like there was a time last year
where a kid came in,
didn't do his homework.
"Why didn't you do your homework?"
"My family got evicted.
We had to move to a car.
We're living in a car."
So you're like "Hand it in later."
It's like what are you going to say?
You can't be angry at the student,
the child because it's
not their fault.
>>Doug: McCarthy is a senator
so that's the Senate Hearings.
What's the other part of our
government- or the congress?
>>My role is more I think in some
respects the guns, the enforcer.
I get to get in people's
faces, I get to yell.
I chase them down.
I'm checking on attendance
if they're cutting a class,
I'm going to find them.
>>I have high expectations of
their behavior, of your schoolwork
and I'm going to do what it takes.
>>These people really care.
These teachers, you know,
they'll help you a lot.
They never let your grades go down.
If your grades go down
you get disciplined.
I've had teachers chase me
because I try to cut class.
Mr. Schaefer, my U.S.
History teacher,
he's jumped a fence just to get me.
>>Peace, love and granola.
Adieu, adieu, adieu to
you and you and you!
>>Just let me say that I
saw Ms. Fields last week.
She had come in because
Keith had a C.
>>Narrator: Since Biotech
teachers meet
for lunch nearly every day they can
share impressions of their students
and intervene early when they
see trouble on the horizon.
>>Sorry that we're here.
Keith is such a great
kid and he's smart
but he's just not using
what he's got.
>>You got support from home.
You've got the ability, you've
got the support in this academy.
There's no reason why you
shouldn't be getting As or Bs.
>>I noticed my mom was mad at
me and she kind of explained
that when we got home and after
that kind of clicked something
and I brought my grades up.
>>Keith is a very good example of
how you can really turn a student
around by just paying
attention to them.
>>This is allele Y.
This is allele X or one
and two as we talked about them.
>>Biotech students
get additional support
and attention outside the
classroom from mentors
at several biotech
companies in Silicon Valley.
>>So we got an unexpected result
so this is what happens
when you do science.
Things happen that
you don't understand.
You have a hypothesis, something
that we think is going to happen.
We do the experiment to see what
actually happens and then you try
to understand it to go back
and change your hypothesis.
>>A lot of these students
are of Latino background
so I think it helps them to see
someone who comes from their culture
as well who has been able to
progress in this particular career
so I think it makes it something
that's more of an option for them.
>>Take ten microliters
from the small tube.
>>As a freshman I just thought I was
going to be a single mother at my age
at 16 or just be nothing.
>>Narrator: For Erica
Diaz the decision
to enter Biotech changed her life.
>>Erika: As a sophomore I said
I want to become a doctor,
but to become a doctor
what do you have to do?
You have to go to school and I guess
that's- that goal started reaching
out like started getting
bigger for me.
>>And every day is like a goal for
me to be in class, to be in school
so I can reach that goal.
>>We had them in the light first
and then we covered the tank
with like black paper so it could
look dark in there and then that's
when they were more sexually active.
>>As the semester drew to a
close, students came together
to assist each other
with preparations
for their final presentation.
>>I think one thing in honors class
if you often see is real competition.
I'm working for that A+.
I got to-- whereas here I think
we've seen more cooperation.
The students realize hey
we're in this together.
And doing group work projects,
we got to do this together.
I think that's a big advantage.
>>The intimacy of this
school within a school
and the group collaboration helped
Berenis Revuelta overcome her shyness
to become a top student.
>>We just wanted to
find out the easiest way
to take DNA from a tarantula.
>>I was like antisocial.
Didn't really get along
with many people.
But having all these kids
in the same like for three
or more classes you kind
of get attached to them.
>>After a summer internship
at Genentech she plans
to enter Chico State.
>>We wanted to see
if over-the-counter steroids had the
same effect as prescribed steroids.
>>Most of my family doesn't end
up like in college and stuff
and all they know is like
Medical Assistants or something,
and so me becoming like a biochemist
or something it will be like, wow,
you're really doing something.
>>Students: Whoo!
>>These are the kind of folks that
have a commitment who are willing
to put their time, their effort,
their hearts out to students
because they understand that
these students will return
that same sort of commitment to them.
>>And these guys had a
difficult time coming to school.
They had a difficult
time telling the truth.
They had a difficult time
keeping focused and I'm so proud
and I don't want to
cry right now but--
>>Student: Griffin!
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org